with a hulking frame burly voice and New
York accent danny aiello seemed destined
to play tough guys on stage and stream
Aiello who has died at the age of 86
didn't turn to acting until later in
life but he left behind some memorable
characters in the great Godfather Part 2
Danny Aiello outlived those
unforgettable words it was just his
second on-screen role Aiello didn't take
to acting until his late 30s born in
Manhattan he had been a soldier baggage
handler and union boss before he began
performing though he soon became an
essential character actor especially as
the role hold for toughness you got a
problem with that Aiello really began to
breakthrough in the 1980s first
alongside Madonna in her video for Papa
don't preach then playing opposite share
in her oscar-winning role in moonstruck
and finally earning an Oscar nomination
himself as a Brooklyn pizzeria owner in
Spike Lee's do the right thing free free
but as Aiello told CBS Sunday morning in
2014 he believed if he won the Oscar
it would have cheapen the awards but I
said if I got it how good could it be
you really believe that that's true why
Danny Aiello come on back into acting
never studied a day in his life I'm not
being cool here I'm telling you straight
though I owe those colleagues expressed
their sadness on social media share
writing at making moonstruck was one of
the happiest times of my life and he was
part of that happy time and Leigh
writing Danny we made cinema history
together would do the right thing may
you rest in paradise every time he was
on screen yeah yeah he was he was a
spectacular human being married to his
wife
sandy Cohen for like 64 years met him
30-something years ago coming off of do
the right thing and as he was filming
Harlem night
and just a stand-up guy a real guy I
mean a real wise guy really athlete on
straight yeah uh certainly a loss